I have a question on going back to the
documentary where do you think that Joe
Joe exotic would be if it weren't for
Carroll Baskin today I think that he's
had a lot of difficulties that have come
up I think there was other difficult
things besides Carroll I think that
Peeta was a real difficulty and a thorn
in his side I think that Joe was too big
and imploding in his own way I think he
was taking on so much responsibility of
so many animals and I think that that is
just a difficulty in itself there's a
certain point that you have to stop you
know if you can properly care for 100
chickens then you've got 100 chickens
and you built a barn from and that's how
it is you had 10 more chickens - there
you start reducing the quality of all
110 chickens now and I think he was
piling it on and that was causing a lot
of pain and suffering for him and that
potentially that was going to expand in
to the staff and to the animals and to
other things it all became tragic in its
own way and it's incredibly difficult to
find people that want to help you so I
had very difficult staff problems you
know he was he was really scraping the
edges sometimes to find people that he
could have do the work there and try and
have the food it cost me a fortune to
feed my cats I have to being a thousand
pounds of food out every day and if it's
not that I would eat or I would expect
my children need I wouldn't expect a
tiger to eat it but they're grabbing all
that old funky meats and secondhand
deliveries and things and that also
creates an implosion things are
unhealthy things can't reproduce things
can't live their best life you everybody
needs care and quality in their life
when you reduce the care you reduce the
quality of the opportunities for them to
eat to sleep for where they can stay
everything oh yes off the edge I was
imploding in his own his own way and I
spoke to him a couple times saying Joe
you've got to
many parts here you got too much going
on you need to worry about care and the
center point here and was he able to
hear that like he referred he's referred
to you or he in the documentary at one
point he referred to you as a mentor and
somebody he really looks up to um was he
able to hear that when you were talking
to him when you kind of when you guys
checked in with each other
he was like I'm I sneeze okay he was
able to hear some of it but hearing it
and enacting it are two different things
saying try and find some better quality
help shoot many restaurants in America
that serve fine food cannot find fine
servers you know many yeah it have great
businesses I've the most difficult time
with staff Joe was at odds trying to
have staff and then he wanted to be
famous you know he got his wish that's
why everybody always even think of
careful with this for Joe's more
famously gonna be right now
you know for him this is the crowning
moment in his career and he's oddly not
even free to see it which is um yeah
which is such a wild thing on the
documentary a lot of uh there seems to
be like a lot of like drug use and
behind-the-scenes drug use and I've used
drugs so I know what it's about but did
you feel like that had a lot to do with
some of the things falling apart over
there in Joe's world yeah I think when
you're using drugs it's much harder to
focus I mean at times throughout Joe's
lights
he used enough drugs that he overdosed
on a number of occasions you know and
that he was looking at some pretty hard
stuff to be recreational recreation yeah
hard drugs that's a very difficult thing
I'd be some recreational alcohol or
maybe people have recreational marijuana
in their life but recreational math man
you're stepping over and meth is a
full-season game you can't ya meth is a
full season it's not a pickup game
you know meth is uh yeah that's a
million quarters dude that's a lot of
over times man and a lot of people
coming to work with him falling into the
same trap how can they possibly provide
the care that you would hope
the people that are continuing in that
kind of shadier side of wildlife that
part of it is probably the most
detrimental thing that can go on you
need that clear head sharp thinking and
focus to make this work out right
the would you ever be up I would be I
would be scared to be on drugs around a
big cat I would be scared to be on drugs
around a big cat how do you feel about
that I'm scared to be around big cats if
I have allergies going on you know I'm
certainly not going to go out there and
have a few drinks and see what's
happening that justice yeah this is this
is a on your toes ready for the serve I
tell people if you don't feel like
you're in a tennis match and that other
guys getting to throw a 100 mile an hour
ball at you right now that you're not
ready for that Tiger to open that door
if you open it you open the door we say
here you go we open the door right up we
say how you doing there Tiger boy come
right here come to me hold we put them
together let's follow wha we have Harry
organized very specific relationships
that we nurture from the time they're
very small were the last ones doing this
kind of action in America it's just
faded away
Jojo is doing it different he was
looking for a tiger that didn't like the
bite very often it's come right
everything cody has not been chewed up I
have never been chewed up in my life um
we have not been harmed on our facility
we've had bumps and scratches and fall
down but we've certainly had far more
trouble with people tripping and falling
with no cats around at any time a cat
hurting somebody it's just not there
that's not part of what goes on yeah I
know yeah Joe's over there he likes cats
I'd like to listen to ac/dc and smoke
cigarettes and some of that stuff blew
my mind like hey I even saw a cat
putting a Copenhagen in his jaw you know
it definitely gets a little more risque
over there at his camp but it seemed
like it was just an every is his whole
Tiger complex that GW spot was just an
example of him it was just
it really is it behaves the way the
owner does it seems like like each one
of you guys is camps kind of follows the
owner very erratic behavior you know and
very much behavior of somehow mimimi and
and how it's gonna reflect look and be
about me not about the animals and
certainly not about the big picture that
wildlife desperately needs the big
picture of what her Tigers doing in the
wild and how are you personally trying
to help I talked with you about that a
couple times trying to get him on that
vein one time he got some money and
raised it I think selling prophylactics
he told me and he raised him for rhinos
and he made a donation to international
rhino foundation so that he could help
save rhinos but it was a one-off he
couldn't keep the momentum he needed the
money for other activities in life I
guess and he just didn't hold it
together you know some unscrupulous
buddies to come along and I think they
tore him down hard as he got more
diversified and who was helping him run
the park I think it's probably the most
dangerous thing he ever did was bring on
more people that were from other more
partners as trouble now he also was Joe
when do you where did you first meet Joe
I first met Joe at a feline conservation
Federation meeting about people that
have animals and how they're gonna care
from what they're doing I was trying to
get it that organization to be able to
experience the wildlife and activities
that I have here maybe 15 years or so
ago he visited because that group was
here visiting and he came through the
facility and he got to see what we're
we're doing and what was happening and
he made application to try and ask the
organization to improve his place give
him tips of what could happen so because
of that I sent him some notes and
letters and things about what he I
thought he should do to improve the
facility and make a better life from the
animals and better life conservation
movement I think Joe had good intentions
of what he was doing I
Joe loved the party and I think Joe was
looking for a party where he could be
the king of that party and there is no
doubt that having exotic animals even
just from a little monkey to a Big O
Tiger with you
creates a something flashy that will
draw someone to you and makes a great
icebreaker for that situation now the
responsibility that comes with it is so
great that it will wash it all away but
you a lot of time it takes people a long
time to figure out the flash of the
tiger comes with an a massive amount of
responsibility and time and the Tigers
not gonna act like a dog unless you
become a world-class trainer which then
requires thousands of hours and then
takes away the party again hmm you know
so I think he was just wishing but you
know what I think
Joe wished is most and did the most as
Joe wanting to be Siegfried and Roy yeah
that's his mentor in his mind I would
say far more I thought I wanted to be
Siegfried and Roy's I think yeah just
just to have that you know wow factor
you know that's why I did the magic and
did other things and I think that all
that was part of what he was chasing he
looked like a really hard worker though
doc I will say that and that's just the
perception I get was he a hard worker I
think he was I think he was working very
hard at a very difficult thing that
would not he could not keep that shift
going I think there he's got a nice ship
they poked a bunch of holes in it and
who's the one back there with the puck
slinging water out as fast as he can
she was going down he's working his ass
off to sling the water out he's right
next to him they're drilling holes
he's on the other side and then the
animal people that he met and the other
con men shysters and losers that got
locked they're drilling holes and Joe's
back there going he'll be that bad but
he's going crazy slinging it over the
side doesn't even realize that it's on
until they pose that thing
metal door behind him to change you know
should he should Joe exotic be in prison
I would guess it certainly a portion of
the stuff that they say he did wrong he
did some of it I would not have been
shocked if they gave him time served
right that's what I thought might even
be there cuz he sat there for a long
time being locked up without being
guilty of anything which always seems
strange when that happened so he's
locked up all that time he's suffering
he's not the healthiest guy and he's
feeling bad in there
and I thought some people I'm shocked if
he got 22 years I think it's a sign of
the times of just you know people saying
that he's gone really too far but the
things that he did wrong are too big but
I'm really not sure that they were near
as big as other criminals in our system
many of whom are even our politicians we
elected and put in office that I think
crossed the line far more heinous than
anything that Joe's done and they float
by so legal systems really hard I think
if Joe was had top-notch attorney but
has spent a few million dollars on his
defense his sentence would have been far
lighter good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one